y at il une culture propre aux banlieues
philly en tout cas un mode de vie
spécifiques de tous ceux qui vivent dans
ces banlieues ce sont en effet des zones
urbaines habité en majorité par des
jeunes se sont aussi malheureusement des
zones où il y a beaucoup de chômage
puisque le chômage touche en priorité
les jeunes reportages sur le terrain à
clichy serge ministre est dernier mais
rioux la banlieue en 88 ce n'est plus
seulement cela des hlm en bordure du
périphérique avec du béton partout
l'endroit idéal pour faire pousser la
graine de violence avec la drogue en
prime
ici on a trouvé une solution une maison
de quartier des étés chauds des
minguettes ont servi de leçon on a
construit avec l'agrément de la
population une maison où on accueille
les jeunes ou un moniteur les aide à
faire leurs devoirs les chômeurs de
demain se sont déjà ceux qui ont du mal
à suivre à l'école
résumé un peu tout ça donc une aide aux
devoirs des loisirs et surtout une
nouvelle approche pour pas que les aînés
soit qui est pas ce qui va
intergénérations aînés
et adolescents et adultes l'autre façon
d'aider les jeunes c'est de leur donner
le moyen de se défouler ensemble c'est
ici que les fils de breton 40% de la
population pour tuer ou algériens se
retrouver dialogue la salle de sport n'a
pas remplacé ce bistrot mais on y
accueille gratuitement les jeunes
chômeurs
beaucoup de problèmes bien sûr le
principe fondamental récent quand même
l'emploi par rapport aux jeunes chômeurs
il faut pas dire que bompard le sport
ils ont toujours pas leurs problèmes au
niveau de l'emploi forem rester assez
souvent à ce niveau là je crois c'est le
premier problème de tous
ils sont tous à la recherche de l'emploi
ils sont peu désorienté ce que les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui
il a plus en plus sur le marché du
travail
ils sont souvent mal dirigé dans leur
formation scolaire ils se retrouvent
avec un ca fait un bep
à l'heure actuelle c'est la course aux
diplômes et si on n'atteint pas le
minimum qui est le bac qui est la
barrière pour les études supérieures
je pense que
on peut pas rêver à grand chose depuis
le temps que dans la ville les bureaux
remplacer logement ceux qui sont venus
vivre de l'autre côté du périph sont
devenus banlieusards ils se sont mis à
aimer leur univers ils cherchent à s'y
fixer et à y travailler comme christian
âgé de 22 ans qui a fondé sa propre
entreprise problème à l'heure actuelle
c'est de se trouver leur leur
personnalité quoi de trouver eux mêmes
ils savent pas ce qu'ils sont exactement
il cherche un peu et à travers de
travail sont encore plus de mal parce
que si traduire ses courses avec
l'emploi précaire
le ras-le-bol des tubes il y a aussi le
logement parler c'est chiant parce qu'on
évoque une c'est vraiment bon c'est
vraiment trop quoi quand tu vas avoir un
studio ses 2500 balle quand tu vas voir
rêve de ces trois mille balles ça c'est
pas suivant c'est pas ce pape aussi même
si tu défense tout boss c'est carrément
impossible la banlieue ça vient aussi
incroyable enfin bon il faut bien que tu
habites les cas pas à clichy où ailleurs
les jeunes de la banlieue ont leur
langage leur art go leur idole coluche
goldman est toujours leurs angoisses
ton chômage mais non
loisirs la culture ah bon je veux dire
c'est surtout trouver une identité dans
la société enfin personnellement c'est
ce que je dirai l'identité ça veut dire
quoi
les entités trouver sa place allons
avoir une raison de vivre sa voix pour
qu'on est là à avoir des objectifs
qu'ils étaient en vie
[Musique]